I hope that the coffee that you have is
going to wake you up in a couple of
minutes so that you can attend to all
our amazing speakers my name is Shawna
and tell I work in Microsoft Research in
Cambridge in the UK and Abbey's hxd
group and we're here to talk about the
future of communication a critical part
of course of the future of work of
course in some ways the futures always
been communication right everybody
always asks well what does the future
hold for communication at work and in
some ways you know the questions are
sort of the same like is it about just
old ways of doing or new ways of doing
old things or are there in fact new
things that are possible being made by
new technologies but how new is anything
really and I think what's great about
this particular panel is it will have
speakers who'll be able to speak to sort
of old sociological and HCI concepts but
also new ways of thinking about those
things and new ways of leveraging those
things for the future of work and that's
because we talk the world of work into
being and so I ask the speakers to
consider these four questions I ask them
to ask how should we cope with the
increasing communication technologies
right all the different ways and all the
different parts of our ecosystems that
we'll need to sort of talk through talk
amongst talk across I asked them whether
there was a communicative backbone to
the work environment and how that
related to communication more generally
I asked them whether communication
patterns are changing and how they might
be able to to map those and ask them of
course to talk about how communication
relates to productivity broadly speaking
the four speakers that we've got are
really tremendous and quite varied so we
have Elizabeth Stokoe
who's professor of social interaction at
Loughborough University a specialist in
conversation analysis which is my sort
of home field as it were and she'll be
talking about agents and agents and
communication how we can build better
agents and in particular the scene but
unnoticed methods that people have for
making themselves understood to one
another and how that might relate to
building better agents then we have
Konstantin Sanders a philosopher from
the University of Hartford sure who are
we talking about how we are
to deal with this sort of increase in
communication technologies and talk
about the concept of unhurried time
making space for unhurried time we've
then got Yvonne Rogers amazing professor
of interaction design from UCL who will
also be talking about agents but in a
different kind of way for than Liz
Nevada we're talking about looking for
intellectually appropriate ways context
appropriate methods context to
appropriate models of interaction and
then finally we'll have the inimitable
bill Boston talking about ubiquity
versus you by to you or your body versus
a big video and they were quite sure
which way these things have to go but
I'm sure he will set us all straight on
this and he may also offer a few
comments on the other speakers as well
we're going to run all the speakers
together and then we're going to have
time for questions and discussion at the
end so please write down your questions
while you hear the presentations and
then quickly raise your hands as soon as
as soon as everybody's finished speaking
and then we can have a really good sort
of interesting discussion so I'm not
going to talk much more because I really
want to make space for our amazing
speakers so in fact I'm going to finish
a little bit early on my section and
bring out Liz to talk about her section
fantastic hello oh the future of
communication is bad it's good job I'm
here to tell you about conversation
analysis this is what I do
I'm a conversationalist and that means
that I study real talk talk in the wild
not talk produced in labs not simulated
interaction or role played interaction
and I don't ask people to tell me later
post talk how they talk I study real
talk and I collect recordings sometimes
single cases sometimes tens hundreds or
thousands of cases of people talking in
real settings doctor-patient police and
suspect people on first dates and then I
transcribed them in a lot of fine
grained forensic linguistic detail to
try and then discern all of the actions
and activities that comprise complete
encounters from the moment they start to
the moment that they end I also do a lot
of public science around conversation
and communication and in a way I have
the opposite challenge
most scientists when it comes to
explaining what we do to it let's say a
lay audience because something like a
black hole doesn't really exist for
humans to understand it but talk and
conversation is is only there for us or
to understand each other and of course
we all talk so we all think we know
everything about talk already
so how do this is this is one of the
challenges that I have is communicating
about conversation analysis to two
audiences who think they already know
about communication and people ask me
questions like this will we still
communicate in the future will I take
over our conversations is SMS ruining
our ability to communicate with each
other and generally I answer that
question by starting with this which is
that we're always going to need to do
things in interaction at least for the
career that I have left hopefully people
will still be needing to do stuff in
interaction so they're going to need to
do things like this this is my dad
talking to alexa okay i'd like to order
a pizza for delivery we're going to come
back to how one orders a pizza for
delivery a little later in my
presentation but i want us to start with
the idea of doing things and in
particular there's something like a
request so when i say that we do things
in interaction and we're going to need
to probably do them for the foreseeable
future i mean things like greetings
assessments we're going to need to make
offers we are going to want to flirt
with each other all of those things are
things that we do in interaction whether
it be written or spoken and the one
action that i'm going to focus on for
the rest of my talk is requests like i'd
like to order a pizza for delivery my
first example shows you how nevertheless
when we think about a request as a broad
action that each each composite word as
one builds the action is crucial and my
example comes from a really dramatic
setting which is police crisis
negotiators talking to suicidal people
in crisis and their request is for the
person that they're talking to to talk
to them so we're zooming in on a very
you know a moment it could be four hours
into the negotiation it could be just
like 10 minutes into the negotiation but
I'm going to show you one way in which
negotiators ask persons in crisis to
talk to them hopefully my audio will
work so here comes the request it's
going to come out in real time line by
line so you experience the interaction
as it actually unfolds and you're going
to see dots and dashes and squiggles on
the transcript which is to do with how
we deliver talk but don't worry about
that you should have the audio which has
also been anonymized can we talk about
how you are what happens next is a
silence it's only seven tenths of a
seconds but it's quite a long silence in
my world know just what I've highlighted
it because I want you to notice that
whatever happens next it's delayed so
here comes the person in crisis
responding to the question no I don't
want to talk and you should be able to
hear even through they're not the
anonymous Asian they're sort of inverted
commas around no I don't want to talk
I'm objecting to the very thing that
you're requesting that I do and then
what happens next isn't more silence so
in this little naturally occurring
experiment of real encounters we see
that requests to talk lead to
disengagement in this setting and of
course in this setting every turn
matters because every time the person in
crisis says something it engages then
they are you know further towards
staying alive rather than jumping off
the roof however there is another way of
asking persons in crisis to talk and if
and it's going to work and you're going
to see it working really rapidly so in
the next clip you'll see how quickly the
person in crisis responds to this
different way of requesting
communication and if it was obvious that
what happens next is the thing that
works then that is what people would do
so here is a negotiator different
negotiation doing something a bit
different
[Music]
so here the negotiator asked the person
in crisis to speak to them and the
overlapping talk from lines two to three
though I've highlighted it you can see
how rapidly the person in crisis starts
to talk now this is just one quick
example from our from our large data set
but what we found was that when
negotiators
request to talk people in crisis resist
talking but when they asked them to
speak they don't resist so every word
matters and the thing is you would never
know this unless you actually bothered
to look at real talk because we don't
really think that people are pushed and
pulled around by language in quite this
way because we don't really look at it
and we don't really take it seriously
enough okay here's my next example which
is that in requests not just the words
that we use to put the request together
matters but what we ask for matters and
where we go um also matters so here are
two people calling the vet and one of
them is a real call in other words this
person really does have an animal and
the other one is a simulated call it's
not a chatbot it's a mystery shopper
whose job it is is to test out how good
the customer experiences is when phoning
the vet they don't have a script they're
just told to phone the vet and and
report back on how good your experience
was so here comes one of the calls okay
and here's another one okay
so in case you are wondering the first
one is the mystery shopper who doesn't
really have a dog she doesn't really
have a puppy at all in the second one
it's somebody who really does have a cat
and they are phoning to make an
appointment and just very basically what
you can see here is that when somebody
is told imagine you've got a pet and I
want you to test out the service they
phone to find out about the cost of the
service they don't phone to do what real
callers do they don't give interactional
tasks to the receptionist that actually
real callers do so we found that pretty
systematically across their data sets
that basically mystery shoppers do not
make the same kinds of requests of the
service provider and that means that
when they go back to their company and
say you know this is our experience
they're not really telling you anything
useful I would argue but there are even
some tiny details which are you may have
noticed as the transcript came out which
is that when people really have an
animal they tend to use the present the
possessive pronoun my to formulate the
request and they don't hesitate
and producing the category of animal
that they're phoning about their
hesitations their little home is
somewhere else in the term whereas when
somebody is a mystery shopper they're
more likely to stumble and repair the
production of add puppy and they're more
likely to use the indefinite article a
to produce that the animal as a category
round rather than the possessive pronoun
my cat so all of these things are you
might think tiny details but of course
they matter when it comes to producing
things like duplex so here is duplex
phoning book and address appointment
just a few lines from the opening calls
that have been made available online by
Google okay so you might think and we
could all think that actually duplex is
getting close to sounding authentic but
as soon as you have start to see some of
the analysis that we produce as
conversation analysts which is on the
precise placement of things like
stumbles and exactly how it is that
people build requests then it allows us
to start inspecting these kinds of data
and sort of raise the bar in terms of
authenticity okay so we're going to come
back to pizza now for my my final
examples in requests I'm gonna say
turn-taking
might be more important than abstract
notions of context now we all know that
one of the challenges to producing at
least turn by turn by turn by turn
interaction with agents and so on is
action recognition and this is partly
because we we know that meaning matters
and we know that context matters but we
tend to prioritize abstract notions of
context over practical action and that
means that we often ignore the detailed
and sequential structure of talk by
emulating scripted or often
stereotypical dialogue and it's so nice
I think to see something like the
mystery shopper study where you've
basically got a human being
so the simulating being another human
being and seeing how do you produce
being another human being when you are
one does what what does it what does it
actually look like and what can we learn
about how mystery shoppers produce tasks
and compare that to something like a
conversational agent also producing a
task so here is a request for pizza and
here hopefully less likely is this is my
dad talking to alexa and the response
[Music]
the top search results for pizza is
kitchen craft masterclass nonstick Pisa
Crispin train Brahman would you like to
buy it now you might think that well
here he hasn't got the right skill he
often asked in the right way for
whatever it is that he might want when
he says I'd like to order a pizza for
delivery but the thing is we can ask the
pizza in lots of different ways and
interrogative grammar produces a request
can I have declarative grammar produces
a request Pizza sounds good you could
say that pizza looks nice and that could
be treated as a request so all of these
different formats for building a request
can lead to challenges but here is the
context in which we originally see why I
got my dad to say dad can you can you
just record yourself asking Pizza in
this way because here is an original
setting in which that turn comes out
[Applause]
okay so now what we have is a really
interesting challenge because if you've
Google you know scam calls fake calls
nine nine nine time wasters and all that
kind of thing you'll find lots of calls
where people are phoning and making
calls that look a bit like this you know
what's the date and my cats up a tree or
whatever it might be but what you're
going to see and you might have guessed
this already of course is that this is
not a request for pizza this is not a
scam call this is not somebody wasting
the time of the dispatcher what this
person means is I'm in danger my
partner's gonna kill me please send the
police that's what she means if you like
so how is it that the dispatcher is
going to discern this and as I play you
the rest of the call until the point of
recognition if you like I want you to
notice not that he
not that he's picking up on words but or
even semantics but he's picking up on
turn-taking placement so I'm
highlighting the bits that I want to
focus on and it's the point at which the
caller comes back to start her turn
which is communicating to him something
like if you were pizza this is where I
would now be taking the next turn and
that is seems to be what he's picking up
on so here it comes
okay I don't know it's wrong with the
audio but I keep going so there what we
see is the call taker the dispatcher
picking up pretty quickly that the this
woman who's asking that for a pizza is
in fact asking for the police the police
are dispatched and they and they they
save the woman from from her partner and
it's gorgeous because it tells you it
gives you it gives us something to aim
for which is to understand not just
abstract notions of context but here the
speaker is able to come back at line 21
there do you know how long it'll be this
is the point where I would be asking you
that question if you were the pizza
person and he's able to discern that
from from turn-taking thank you very
much
thanks very much Liz that was phenomenal
so you have questions about Liz's
amazing talk chilling talk really please
write them down now so that you can ask
her at the end now I'd like to bring out
konstantin sanders to talk about a
future for unhurried a time and hurry
communications hi I was going to have a
handout because I'm a kind of old
fashioned philosopher but I'm trying to
persuade you that I'm not a Luddite at
the end of this talk so I thought I
should stick with slides and let's get
started so we all know about the gains
of communication technology I don't need
to tell you about the gains of technical
communication technology but every gain
has losses and there are different kinds
of losses that come with different
technologies I want to focus on
psychological ones and what I'm going to
call fecundity costs and I'm using the
term for Kunda T in sort of jeremy
bentham sense of if there's some utility
to the technology or to anything that
utility doesn't bring further utility so
the utility doesn't reproduce in a
different sense tech communication
technology does have fecundity in the
sense that the more you use it it kind
of replicates itself and it's kind of
designed in many cases to be used more
and more so the more you use it the more
you need to use it but I want to say
that this has a kind of cost in terms of
productivity in a certain sense of the
term so for example we might have
technologies where you get notifications
that someone has read your message and
it makes us it's designed so that we use
it more and more and you might think oh
we're more productive the more we use
the technology the more we're doing
things and I want to suggest that doing
things being busy is not the same as
getting things done
likewise we have all these notifications
popping up telling us something's
happened
check this check that and it makes us
kind of active but in a way which
I think has a utility costs of a certain
kind now you'll see a message from my
from a friend and scholar who I deeply
respect so I haven't put her surname on
there but I get this message and hands
up I was on I was on Facebook doing
things I don't know what hi Constantine
I see you are constantly active on
Facebook but did you receive my email
send a feedback please Marina and now
her email had come an hour before and it
was four chapters of her book with the
request for feedback right so for the
kind of thought that oh look you haven't
had time for for my book you're doing
this stuffy the expectation to reply why
because someone has seen that I am
online right that's the point they've
seen I'm online and they haven't had a
response to their email and as the
online offline distinction begins to
collapse a danger is that the kind of
distinction between the workplace and
home or any other place outside of work
also begins to collapse so if like me
you sometimes take a commuter train
you'll see people who are already
working on their phones on the way to
work and on the way back from work but
that that work while technology can
allow us to not be in at work and do
things from home or from wherever we
need to be it can also in many cases
people are just working before and after
work but it's not getting rid of
anything in between so these are some
some of the dangers and they come with
high psychological costs we heard in
some of the keynotes this morning
worries about stress anxiety and this
sort of permanent state of work this is
from a book that I be sellin who who's
here co-wrote some time ago now the myth
of the paperless office and they write
the use of email in an organization
cause
an average 40% increase in paper
consumption now initially some of that
increases because people would print out
emails and we do that a little less now
than we used to so there was this kind
of treating the email as anything else
and then printing it but it wasn't the
only thing one other thing that sellin
and Harper talked about is that things
that would have a high cost in terms of
time or money to do physically come very
very cheap in terms of time and money
electronically like sending various
kinds of forms the longer the form the
longer the document you would think
twice about do we really need this
electronically you don't think about
this as much it's just an attachment or
three attachments or four attachments
and before you know it you have this
kind of world in which people are
sending forms left right and center
things to fill in spreadsheets and so on
that they wouldn't have done before and
everyone is kind of busy and I've had
I've had colleagues in academia who feel
a sense of you know research can take a
very long time and they get a sense of
satisfaction that I've done five things
today because I went to the exam board
and I fill those documents and I filled
my five-year plan or whatever and I did
my form for I don't know what and
there's a sense of oh I got this stuff
out the way I've been efficient but
actually it's stuff that you in a way
didn't need to do an entire rolls get
created by people giving you this stuff
to do and then so then it's their job to
do it so then they've got to do more of
it and then you're sort of thinking
you're being efficient by doing these
things and so you're always doing things
but are you getting anything done so
some people talk of unhurried
conversation about slowing things down
I'm going to talk as fast as I can about
slowing things down in the next five
minutes and there's a sense you might
think that there's something sort of
maybe lazy about being unhurried
strolling in the park so on and so forth
and you might think oh you know this
guy's coming here to tell us to just
kind of work
less but that's not really what it's
it's about I'm gonna give you a
quotation just from a personal letter
this is from my favorite philosopher
Ludwig Wittgenstein
and he says my father was a businessman
and I am a businessman - I want my
philosophy to be businesslike to get
something settled to get something done
so that's got the sense in which there's
something we're trying to sort out and
our work is to do it right there's
nothing kind of lazy relaxed or
leisurely about it in a way he's quite
an intense guy to be honest but there
isn't this faffing around this doing all
these busy bodying things there's just
the thing we need to get done and in
order to do this in in various
disciplines it requires us to understand
our colleagues to understand the person
with whom you're trying to get something
done and that's something which I think
fast communication can be an obstacle to
now this is part of a general movement
and like all movements we should be
somewhat suspicious of it I'm not going
to read everything out on this list in
front of you and you'll be glad to know
I'm not going to talk about everything
on this list in front of you and you can
get this kind of suspicion of well why
should we suddenly is this just the
latest fad why should we suddenly do
everything slowly Vick and Stein who I
quoted before also thought that
philosophers should treat each other
with the salutation go slowly and he
sells he says elsewhere in philosophy
the winner is the one who finishes last
that's going to be built today by the
way but but there's this thought that
when you're thinking when you're doing
certain things you do you take a certain
care in them if you do it slowly and if
there's the sense of why didn't you
respond to my article to my book to the
you I've seen that you've read my
message and
so I'm on the train with all these
people and they're sort of I can hear
what they're saying and nothing is
really happening and that's time that
could be used much better and this isn't
about philosophy this is about thought
more more generally there's a book which
I haven't finished because I've been
reading it slowly called slow media and
Jennifer raunch writes who wrote it
writes many people have found their
mediated lives to be too fast too
digital to disposable and too distracted
and she kind of tries to fight this with
things like localism self-reliance
fairness and so on so in a sense what
we've been experiencing is there's been
this kind of phase where everyone was
always on their phone online doing this
doing that and then people sort of
suddenly are moving towards I don't know
listening to vinyl and sort of staying
away from social media and there's a
kind of reaction to this stuff and so
there's a kind of question here how
reactive are the things I'm saying now
slow media and the other kind of slow
things I've been talking about so far
are a little different from from slow
communication and I want to end with
some thoughts about what I've been
calling on hurry time now and we heard
some things this morning about the right
to disconnect for example and over lunch
I've been talking with people with
various ideas that I call patches about
how to fight this kind of pressure to
always be doing things but never getting
anything proper done so we people have
different strategies about checking
email or blocking email from coming
disabling notifications dumb phones that
only let you do certain things with them
and so on but and I think while these
things are all well and good they're
really just patches and what I mean by
this is that there's something negative
that we're trying to kind of stop to try
and keep in control but
they're not something positive and it's
not the creation of new technology that
enable that enables us to think slower
and to get serious things done and I
think this requires reimagining what
communication is for and I think the
clues kind of in the name information
communication technology there's a
there's an assumption that communication
is there to exchange information
it's philosophical roots go all the way
back to John Locke the philosopher but
it's there in a lot of contemporary
stuff and if you think that the purpose
of communication is to exchange
information then all you're really
interested in is how much information
can I exchange and how fast can I
exchange it and you and there's no so
it's all about volume and speed in a way
but I think we need to rethink what
technology what communication could be
for and in this particular context I'm
interested in what it could be for
within the workplace but I think there
are wider questions I've talked a bit
about understanding one another how can
we use technology to better understand
one another speed is not often a good
way of understanding other people and
you I'm sure you've all experienced what
happens when we all too readily reply to
an email for example getting things done
I've spoken about and also other things
like building camaraderie between
colleagues this is something that
technology can be can be used for and
these are just kind of a few thoughts
I'm not trying to quickly provide an
answer to everything but I do think we
need to rethink what communication is
for thanks very much thank you can't
think that was fantastic all right now
it's my great pleasure to invite to the
stage you von Rogers
good afternoon how many of you have an
Alexa at home put your hands up I'd say
that you are representative of most
people in the US and the rest of the
world they are becoming part of the
family home and whenever I tell people I
do research in this area they always
tell me an anecdote about how it's
changed their family life how are these
types of devices going to affect work
and my talk is going to be about
thinking about how these types of voice
interfaces can be used in business I
want to go back in time though back in
the 80s when small groups collaborated
and how did they do that around
technology well one of them would have
the mouse and the others would look on
and they you might be able to grab the
mouse or wait until someone would pass
it to you and then there was the vision
of people in Star Trek talking to the
ship's computer where they all could
interact and have multiple devices so
there's a big difference between then
and the Star Trek I want you to look at
the affordances now of these smart
speakers and you can see here these this
family are playing in that game are
paper scissors and stone with the device
and the their attention is very much
towards the device but also each other
and so it sits in the middle between
these people here now look at where
alexis has been developed in business
and the idea is that they're going to be
used increasingly at work and it's going
to be you know placed somewhere in on a
table in meeting rooms and there are
many claims that are being made about
what voice user interfaces can do for
businesses and it's very apt for this
conference but sorry the summit that the
focus is largely on productivity and
efficiency gains and there's claims
being made that they can provide an
intelligent a system that will help
people with their tasks in particular
providing ways of scheduling meetings
and while they're doing their
multitasking they can write up notes for
you make suggestions and collect
resources
all enabling people to work more
efficiently and has also been claims
made that they can improve communication
and in particular the claims that are
being made is that they will be able to
listen to conversations during meetings
and they'll be able to make notes on
important points and they'll be able to
help employees identify and retrieve the
right information that they needed
particular times from various sources
and as I already said they'll be able to
create reminders summarized and tasks
and so on and so they will be these
types of assistance that will do things
in the background and this is voice
Sarah's Ava and as you can see she's
listening to what people are saying and
then writing this down and summarizing
it and so we're all working in a
background to make the the workers life
more efficient now my question is can
they be more than a flying cliffy can we
do more with voice user interfaces than
have them doing our tasks in the
background and that's the research that
I'm currently doing with them Leon and
Ethan looking at how we might rethink
voice assistance as voice collaborators
and what we're doing is trying to design
voice collaborators if you like and
we're doing this by thinking about when
can they be proactive as opposed to
always being reactive so currently you
will ask your voice assistant questions
and what we're thinking about is what
would happen if if the voice assistant
could ask you questions or make
suggestions to you whilst you're working
so how do we think about switching that
what sorts of roles might they play
could they be a moderator in a meeting
could they be a facilitator they
facilitate conversation could they be an
instructor they can instruct you what to
do and if we are shifting I'm thinking
about voice our user interfaces when and
how should they intervene in human
conversation should they but in like
human beings do in conversations or
should they be more polite and also how
should they be incorporated into the
existing ecosystems not Ecology's
thank you very and so what we're trying
to do is to think about how we can turn
virtual assistants into virtual
collaborators and we're doing this by
doing two strands of research one is to
you think about how we might use AI to
understand conversations and context
awareness in order that when these voice
assistants are going to interrupt or
make suggestions it's timely and that
they don't disturb or disrupt ongoing
group working and then we think that
making them human-like is also important
and not too so that the people think
that they don't really are humans but
that they are polite and they behave
like humans so people will take them
seriously and adding the arms and our
house makes them seem more human-like so
those are the two strands of research
that we're looking into and what we're
trying to do is we want to not to make
people's work more efficient or to
optimize their tasks but we want to to
amplify human cognition to if you like
empower people and so our focus is not
to design a general voice user interface
but for specific context and we're
working with Great Ormond Street
Hospital looking at how clinicians who
discuss emerging data clinical data how
we could help them to think about the
data and come up with different
explanations and and ways in which to
use that data so just as in the previous
talk I'm all for slowing down
interaction rather than speeding it up
and to get people to externalize their
thoughts and doing this we're arguing
that that's this can help with creative
exploration of ideas and also
potentially leading you to think
differently to go down different routes
and avenues about what the data is that
you're looking at and even to see new
connections so our aim is very much to
encourage more talk around the
technology rather than trying to speed
up what people do so what we did it's
currently doing is developing a system
called voice phase
and it's a multimodal interface and you
can see the Alexa there and Alexa or
this device here is being designed in
conjunction with data visualizations and
the way in which it works is that we
have used existing clinical data and
this is about obesity levels and that
the voice fist can make suggestions to
small groups about what they might want
to look at next and they can talk with
voice fist to ask it to show different
types of data and this data that we're
using is quite simple at the moment to
make our lives easier but it's looking
at obesity levels for developing and
developed countries for boys and girls
and for adults and children and even
with those variables it can be quite
complex as to looking at trends over
time so we are modeling or trying to
think about the conversational
mechanisms rather than trying to do
natural language processing and some
monitor aspects of the conversation as
to when it's opportune or appropriate to
intervene during conversations so we're
looking at metalinguistic meta
linguistic features the silences that
might go in the arms the arse the pace
of speech the velocity of it the number
of questions asked the body movement the
head movements we're looking at a number
of these things as to see which of these
might be useful to use to know when to
intervene and our output from visi is to
make suggestions at opportune times for
people looking at the data so things
like do you need a hint for analyzing
this variable what do you think of this
shall we move on did you consider the
difference between developing and
developed countries what might have
caused the sudden spike in the data and
if I would say one of them is slowing
down in recent years which one would you
say it is so it's constrained what visi
can say by the context and that makes
our lives a lot easier so here we are
currently running experiment looking at
whether or not having voice inputs and
voice
output actually encourages people to
speak more and to discuss the data and
we're comparing it with a touch
interface to show whether or not or to
investigate whether or not there is a
difference in what people say and do
having voice input and output or just
voice output so we are using a Wizard of
Oz technique for those of you who are
not familiar if you look at the image on
the right
that's our Wizard of Oz he is pretending
to be busy and will press buttons to
give canned speech at appropriate times
and can hear the participants in the
other room what they're saying and what
they're discussing so this is some of
the participants and you can see pieces
of paper on the table and those are
things that they commands that they can
say to visi to change what's appearing
on the screen and sometimes when they
are a bit stuck they've been asked to
describe or to explain the data that's
appearing it visi will say something so
let me see if this will play so they're
not saying anything so they won't say
anything visi says something and that
triggers a discussion and then when they
get stuck visi might interrupt
if I would say one of them is slowing
down in recent years which one would you
say it is so that again they was they
weren't really sure what to say visi
into interrupts and that triggers a
conversation to continue but this is
only human and sometimes visi gets it
wrong and will think that there's a
silence and will interrupt the flow of
conversation and as we know in humans
we're having a you know talking to
someone if someone tries to interrupt
and that can derail our train of thought
so here is an example so they were able
to get back on track but what we're
looking at is when our opportune times
for the viz to be able to interrupt and
to make suggestions if you like to
scaffold the ongoing conversation so
we're currently finishing off running
our participants look at comparing the
voice condition with the touch condition
these are some of the initial findings
which we're finding that participants in
the voice condition whereby they speak
the commands and visi speaks back they
speak more loudly to each other and
expressively so there's more intonation
is the pitch of their voices is L more
loud and that they more thoroughly
explore the data visualizations that
appearing on the screen there's more
in-depth discussion and identification
of trends going on and that they all
spend more time actually looking at the
visualizations whereas in the touch
condition where they just touch a touch
screen when they want to ask physi
something they'd sometimes miss patterns
in that and trends in the data so the
power of voice here is that it can
trigger people to discuss more outside
of what's appearing on the screen so I
just want to I'm coming towards the end
of my time
we're looking at these as proposed
features to model when to intervene in
calm
Visayan so turn taking patterns we heard
in the first talk is an important
speaker activity shared attention the
commands given by whom and the degree
and the speed of exploration or of the
datasets appearing on the visualizations
so I don't have time to go through our
system architecture but we are
developing an architect by which to
analyze what's being said and just to
summarize I think that the value of
voice user interfaces in workplaces we
can think differently about those we can
encourage more discussion and even more
equity of participation so busy could
say Yvonne you haven't said anything for
a while what do you think and we can
introduce something like that it can
increase creativity by exploring
different trains of thought and
questions and most importantly we want
to switch from voice assistants to voice
collaborators and when to intervene a
when voicing assistants should intervene
um is key challenge and finally I was
struck by a paper I read where it's
saying that simple models of
conversation can lead to surprisingly
complex emergent outcomes we don't need
to do a full scale and natural language
processing if you have a constrained
context and the context here is one that
looking at data visualizations and
discussing those and so we're able
perhaps to get by with just doing simple
analysis of what's being said what
mechanisms are being used in order to
think about interventions and I think at
that point I'd like to say thank you
very much thank you very much Yvonne and
now last but not least of course we have
the amazing bill Buxton to give us some
amazing thoughts both on his stuff and
also of course wrapping up and some
thoughts about the speakers so however
in some sense this whole session is each
of the talks fold into the same talk
from just different perspectives but
just as this session to the previous
session on devices working together is
another chapter in the same talk and
just as Sarah or glorious Marx talked
earlier is actually part of the same
talk
in the same session and it's really
interesting to see how these things
scaffold them each other so and some of
that's actually kind of backs it but
some of it's not and I'll try and keep
that in mind as I go along I'm gonna
start with the this is a picture of
Mabel and Mabel was a motorcycle I used
to have said yeah w 900cc
I took to Cambridge with me I flew it
over when you could do that for $200
from Toronto to Cambridge with my
seven-year-old son and we landed at
Stansted putting our letters hook up the
battery and just drove up the Cambridge
and I would tell you that because my son
was 7 he had a very very short attention
span he had some learning disabilities
issues at that time and to keep him
falling asleep on the pillion on the
back seat especially because we just
come on an overnight flight I had a
little microphone and we drove to
Cambridge and I'd never had a
conversation a sustained conversation
longer than two minutes or a few minutes
with my son up in the first seven years
I think that's maybe an exaggeration and
faulty memory but but the fact was that
really poor microphone with the ambient
sound of the wind and everything else
the entire drive through Stansted to
Cambridge we had a completely sustained
fully engaged conversation one which in
some way senses wasn't repeated for
another 10 years in terms of its
coherence and length now what's
interesting is allowing that
conversation is saying Wow is it
evergreen it's amazing and stuff like
that but we kept the thread through that
whole thing and for me that's always
been a reminder that if you take away
bandwidth and you take away modalities
you can sometimes improve the
communication because it's focused and
there's nowhere else to go
the distract even though the scenery's
there there's a different kind of
distraction that caused interruptions
the server is talking about earlier
that's stuck with me and so I'll give
you another example how that dist
anecdote which is just helped shape my
my thoughts comes into this I work with
a couple really neat people here in a
project called soundscape project which
is basically using 3d space
Audio to enhance mobility for people who
are sight impaired and one of the
founders of that project is guy named
Amos Miller who lost the sight just
around the time he graduated from
University and he is insane actually in
the most delightful way he decided that
he was going to run a regatta kayaking
regatta for blind people who had never
been in a kayak before and haven't go
into a competition on Lake Sammamish
just down the road from here and what
they were doing and this is one of the
participants and and this is a guest
last October and the map and the right
sort of shows and what he did is he put
markers like any sailboat race or boat
regatta that you had to follow a course
of seven markers now the markers were
spatial markers which are put on the
lake they were virtual locked and sound
but because of this special audio that
enabled you to hear things outside your
head in locked in in space it's that
kind of augmented reality using
non-speech audio and that's really
important the communication was
non-speech blind person was in the helm
piloting a sighted person was in the
front of the do two-person kayak and
first of all all of them never haven't
been in a kayak before finished the
course and that was so first of all he
the audacity to even do this in the
first places is I told Amos he's crazy
don't do it and and he did and I was
wrong and he was right but here's the
point then we put some sighted people in
the boats with the same headset the same
software and the blind people kicked
their ass he sir asked us well why
because they're so ocular dominated that
they were being distracted and
second-guessing and audio had been
pushed into the background and they knew
how to hear but they clearly didn't know
how to listen and they didn't know how
to listen with confidence that's my
theory no proof okay that's not
experiments that's my interpretation
and I'd argue that there's these
potentials and humans for communication
let's go way beyond speech and this
obsession with speech it's important
it's hard but it's not sufficient but
also to look at these edge cases and see
where we might be able to learn and also
learned that we can provide information
in the periphery the same way you can
tell if it's raining or windy or or if
there's a car coming without interfering
with the foreground task and so you can
push things in the periphery and there
do all of our design issues have been
around foreground intentional actions as
opposed to background peripheral in what
and Sarah Bly and um come to a minute
when they're talking about big screens
thinking about them as information
service awareness service how do you
serve up awareness in a way that's not
interfering with your foreground tasks
and so you can actually focus and not be
interrupted and integrate sometimes that
knowledge and the lessons here are
really important to think not only
because I think it's a it's a great
project but in terms of what we can
learn from it we can bring to the rest
of our practice now there's this whole
tension that's in AI and anything so
it's strong specific week general
systems and that the and the conflict
between the two but there's two Swiss
Army knives here now Victoria Knox that
make Swiss Army knives is probably one
of the companies was most influent
impacted negatively from 9/11 because we
saw all carry these little pocket knifes
with us and none of us do who go on
airplanes because they keep getting
confiscated but I want to point out the
difference between the little one which
I own and the big one which I also own
the big one cost me four but I'm like
four hundred dollars has 80 some odd
tools in it and and there's it's really
interesting because the big one has
everything and it's useless except as a
piece of art or a piece of absurdity
where's the little one which has way
fewer tools because it's always with you
and it doesn't interfere it brings real
value but the choice of tools are really
important and yet there's no tool in
that big one which I don't use sometime
but what we miss in this and I'd argue
that that big one is what people have in
their mistaken interpretation of what
Mark Weiser meant when he spoke about
ubiquitous computing that's what I think
it is the Internet of Things we're just
going to populate the world everything's
everywhere all the time for everybody as
opposed to a few things
they're the right things at the right
person the right time the right place
that are with you some of which are
portable and wearable with you but the
rest are better than the environment
using the Swiss Army knives it's a
really good example it seems to me the
primary use of that big one is on a
camping trip is to use it as a boat
anchor now one of the ways you can look
at this is this if you look at that big
one these are just some of the tools my
weight has two socket wrenches not just
one is you get the tools you can this
all saw spoon fork scissors leather
punch and nail file corkscrew we can say
well what's the function but as soon as
we've done that we look at the functions
and map them to the tools you can
associate a place with every one of them
so why would you have them in places
where they're not typically used and
don't design so you always say well that
might I just might need it I might need
no did some work on the probabilities in
general this is where you need it park
it there and then take special action
for special cases as opposed to be
prepared all the time Saul Greenberg has
spoken in their session before we go
back country skiing now we can load up
our packs with safety gear for every
eventuality but we so overloaded we're
gonna never get up the mountain that
we're trying to climb up to ski down you
have to find a compromise in a ballast
in that as you do in what we do and the
core of this it seems to me was came
from an exhibition I went to I think it
was in Munich or Vienna of Louie Kahn's
work who's one of my favorite architects
and he has this line which i think is
fantastic thoughts exchanged by one
another are not the same in one room as
in another their semantics based in
location and place matters place space
and place and space in every dimension
time relative places of a talk overseer
I'm coming really close to get it closer
right there's a very different thing if
it was a stranger and not a photographer
it would be a different act even though
in the same room I'm in the front but
because I'm in the front I'm the speaker
you're not anybody the back of the room
knows that even if they're from a
different culture it's it goes beyond
being in a room it's and it's the
movement and a gesture of movement as
well that's really critical and it's
within the room and so I'll give you
some examples of just some work that
Abby's Ellen and I and some others did
at Toronto and this is actually a floor
plan of my office and this is work that
dates back to some about 89 to 94 so
that's my office you get my desk as part
of obvious where it is it's the one on
the top left corner and so when I'm
sitting at my desk and I'm working
there's my workstation as of 1993
probably and if somebody comes in to
join me electronically from telepresence
where should they sit if we're having a
conversation
well they across the desk and
principally or beside me at my desk
however you want to imagine it but where
we have a shared workspace and it's
intimate because we're producing work
but a certain type of place but I would
tell you it's very very clear that if
you're a student I'm about to give you a
congratulations or say you're you failed
they're gonna sit in the far side of the
desk I'm gonna be sitting this side and
they would never come to my side that's
something that Abby would do because
she's a close colleague but that's a lot
of interesting permission that if you're
there and I'm here I'm professor Buxton
and you're not and it's a formal stance
if you're calling in a friend that's it
differs there's these permissions this
is called the moral order and this is
kind of stuff that I've learned from
Richard Harper that that this whole
notion about how we start to define
space and movement and and and from
these knowledge --is which are
culturally specific and and and and can
evolve we can decide how to make
informed decisions to limit where we put
technologies that don't need to be there
in the first place
so we can always try to keep to the
minimum necessary to achieve our goals
and we say the same thing if somebody
comes to the door I know if they're at
the door in the middle talking to
Abigail and we're having a conversation
I can complete
lately and politely ignore them and if I
ignore them for 15 seconds they know I
see them I know they see me and and they
will leave and I'm not gonna interrupt
the flow of the conversation because
they have that awareness that I'm in a
conversation and they know that moral
order and the soul and the social mores
and they will just apart in about that
amount of time because of where they're
located they're not in the room and and
away you go
and so you build a proxy to do that so
we place the video there and what I'm
trying to say here is by putting the
more of the right technology in the
right place for the right function then
you have less complexity for every
location in this room there's a place
for the remote person to occupy you no
matter that's consistent with the social
mapping of that space and so even when
they're approaching down the electronic
corridor you use aircon so you can hear
the virtual footsteps coming so as they
approach you can hear them coming to
repair it's not a sudden switch it's an
analogue gentle approach because this
approach graceful approach departure
which came up in Sara's talking came up
earlier today I mean in the session as
well and and then if you are going to
sit around in a collegial way around the
table there should be a place there to
occupy and if you do not have those
things the conversations going to be
broken because you cannot use transfer
the skills that you've acquired from the
lifetime and living in everyday world to
the this hybrid virtual physical space
as you and so you have to think of all
these ways to go over these speed bumps
and you cannot have flow you cannot have
inner uninterrupted and if you look at
your conference rooms for example how we
think about these things and by the way
this has nothing to do so far with what
the technologies are is simply where
they're deployed and remember this has
all been done and working and
functioning in in in in the 19 it laid
it 80 80s and early 90s when I'm giving
a presentation at the front of a
conference room Isis now I'm up front my
work is up front this is before you had
projectors that cost less than a hundred
thousand dollars and so we had at the
time what I thought was a huge display
but I'm working there and I can write on
with a light panel where you go but when
Gayle is now you're looking at it for
back from the front of the room
presenting to the group the audience is
in front of her around the table and
there is a proxy at the back so she can
see one of the team members who's from
Ottawa putting up their hand ask a
question and they're seated where the
audience is seated even today in
Microsoft we I'm typically if I come
into a meeting I'm on the projector at
the front ten times bigger than anybody
else in the room peering down and it's
completely inappropriate and it's got
nothing to do with her ability to have
the technologies it's not understanding
the relationship at technologies
function place and what the moral order
is and how conversations work it's the
social science and the architecture
that's broken not the technology the
digital technology but the main point is
there's a total awareness of what's
doing and and you can use the skills
raise your hand
you got a question that's fine I don't
screw around and see this person looming
don't worry do you have a question and
likewise if the remote person's there
they have a separate space where they
appear on the smaller screen and their
talk is on the big screen you do not put
the if you have your face of the real
person on the same screen as the work
with the camera somewhere built in the
screen it's already broken
it's not about interface design it's out
of my face design get your face out of
my work that's my works place but I'd
love you to be here so I can have gaze
awareness that you're here and the works
there and I can direct your voice you
voice is going this is all things
attributes of how we design and lay out
the technology architectural if you will
that actually takes out the speed bumps
it gets rid of these interactions and if
you start to go back and if you had this
type of architecture I would love to
have glorious studies about where the
eyes go redone because they would change
dramatically because actually the
movement from eye to that screen that
that screen would be show the continuity
of action and the continuity of
conversation as opposed to the
disruption of the conversation it's not
about the screens it's about the content
of why you're going the screens and how
these things chunk together and if we
come back where the task space is in
fact the person they're just giving a
talk with no slides and they should be
up at the front full size in the case we
only have a big screen
skree at the front so what does this all
bring us to in terms of how we think
about things so I worked I had she had
the pleasure of working for a number of
years with Mark Weiser on the ubiquitous
the ubiquitous computing was coming up
this sort of most intensely from let's
say 89 to to Adelaide's 94 but in his
paper the computer for the 21st century
he talked about ubiquitous computing he
talked about this notion of equity which
none of us knew the word we all had to
look it up and and and but these two
principle were is that things were worth
everywhere you needed them and they were
transparent and that sounds like a
paradox but just my example of that is
simply saying if you walk in my house
you come to the living room to see and
the dining room you see a dining room
table the dining room and then you have
to go the washroom you see a toilet in
the washroom you come out there's you go
to ignore it it's transparent in the
same house same person everything else
they put the toilet in the dining room
and they put the dining room table in
the bathroom all of a sudden it violates
the moral order and you will notice that
really will I mean it's you're probably
gonna start questioning the relationship
with me that that that's the situation
I'm just saying it's not about the
visibility of the toilet or the dining
room table it's where they're situated
and and and is it appropriate to the
purpose in the function and and the
moral order of that particular culture
and so what happened is ubiquitous has
this notion and its definition if you
look it up on the Oxford English
Dictionary is everything everywhere all
the time for everybody it's it's
ubiquitous and we think about that
because we're geeks and to think about
the technology because we're
materialistic we think of that
everything is everywhere as opposed
everything we need is everywhere we need
it that's okay but that's not how the
Internet of Things and so on interpret
it mark used the wrong word there is
another word that's adjacent a close
cousin that I only discovered because I
was trying to look up I just am obsessed
with this kind of stuff there's a few
things I'm anal about and one of them is
I really
understand the language and I
accidentally and trying to get the
precise definition in the OED for
ubiquity I came across a word you by
a--they and you by T has a very
different notion the core of it is this
notion of place that it's and so it's it
has this thing and place in every
dimension what Mark talked about was you
buy ax T not ubiquity and likewise
nobody knows this term so of course it's
neutral its unencumbered with baggage
and so then one of my things here says
by changing our language I let's switch
over there so I believe that we can get
rid of the speed bumps and we can get
rid of them by using this notion of
design think about things architectural
II and understand that and this comes
back to the early talk to get away
besides part of communication is to be
able to commune commune with nature
commune with your environment commune
with your family and so you have that
peace and it is slow and it can be
peaceful and thank you alright so I want
to invite now all the speakers back onto
the stage and we can have some questions
so I'm sure you've been industriously
writing down during the during the time
all right here though are bill LaVon Liz
and Constantine so some questions from
the audience
I know so on great thanks everyone for
all of those inspiring talks I wanted to
explore this notion of conversational
agents and whether they need to be
human-like so this is something that you
said Yvonne can you unpack that a bit
because there are many reasons why you
might want to do that or not do that so
is it about natural language
understanding is it that they're
contextual is it that you want some
notion of emotion embedded in these and
especially in a business context why is
that important
I'm not sure that I completely buy it so
maybe you could convince me that's a
good question and I think we made that
decision as to not so how is that our
voice assistant going to appear if it's
going to interrupt would people take it
seriously would they listen to busy
saying something and we thought if we
made it more human-like they may based
on earlier work from the Stanford Nass
but if it's polite then people will
respect it so that's basically our
that's our take on it
it's not about emotional contact that
people will relate to it more it's more
that they'll take it more seriously and
in this context the business contexts
that we think it's important that they
will listen and they will respect what
the the agent is saying I think in other
contexts it may be that you don't want
it to be human-like and I think the the
the ongoing debate about duplex about
whether you're duping people into
thinking it's human when in actual fact
it's it's an agent I think that's a
different context and people don't like
the fact that they're being duped in
this context we're using it people know
it's an agent and it's been designed to
be polite and civil I want to get a
clarification because there may be it
duplex domains means it's two-way
conversation as opposed to duping
but in the telecommunication so did but
but the two points are perhaps the
biggest but also in speech the languages
are using spoken language in both cases
and the thing I find interesting in some
cases that it's less common in the world
is that speech is answered by non speech
or by gesture or by some other mode and
that's far more common when we deal with
technology and therefore the two
directions could be in completely
different modalities I agree and maybe
they have to compensate for the fact
that you can't gesture if you're a voice
assistant and to think about how you can
do that and so you know having the arms
and the arse maybe and the way in which
we use those in human speech can
compensate for the fact that you're not
being able to gesture and use nonverbal
body language which is what we do on the
phone of course yes your case is really
interesting because the having a video
forum would preclude order in pizza and
it would it wouldn't be another example
where it would be damaging it would be
wrong I mean it wouldn't you'd lose that
opportunity to that person take that
strategy of ordering pizza which is
pretty honest in your example there's
also you had went your example of Google
duplex had an arm before the very last
word seventh that was is there a
reasoning that you know about why they
decided to delay that last particular
piece of information because you know in
advance talk it was she said there might
be some value in putting in arms and
hours so one value might be to delay
what might be the value of delay or for
that example but maybe more generally
well some colleagues and myself they
were looking at those very small number
of recordings that duplex have released
into the wild for people like me to look
at what we're trying to look at is is
what what is duplex doing that is sort
of passing for human and where is it not
really passing for human so we're
looking for example at the precise
phonetic qualities of the arms and
finding where they are in duplex is
overall speech sort of
pitch range for example and finding it's
not just that the ohms and ours may or
may not be in the right place in overall
turn construction compared to a human
being booking a hairdressing appointment
for example but that the onset of the
pitch is not quite how you would expect
a human to use that long as well and
it's not really that we're trying to be
critical of duplex it's more like if you
really want to push it as far as you can
then you need to take seriously that you
can find out this kind of stuff when you
study real human it's booking Harrod
deafening appointments for example the
question so constantine talked about all
of this sort of acceleration that
technology is imposing on us making
everything happen really really fast and
so i wanted to toss out one way in which
it may be going the opposite direction i
have found over the past years that sort
of messaging mediums texting or
messenger or whatever they allow these
conversations to happen which is where
sort of the turn-taking is on the order
of hours and so the conversation can be
sort of day-long conversation where you
don't have the rush to to immediately
answer you you don't need to to have the
right thing to say right away you can
sort of think a little bit before the
next step and so yes if you think of
them as isolated messages there may be
the sense of rush but over over a longer
time span there is this kind of coherent
conversation that's happening that could
not happen in person because nobody
would be willing to wait that patiently
for the responses yeah thanks now that
sounds right and one thing I wanted to
say was in a way what I was trying to do
isn't quite the slow media and the other
slow movements because they have this
sort of sense that almost everything
should be slowed down for its own sake
or something like that that's maybe
exaggerating a bit but that kind of
thought is there whereas we do want I
took
that's flexible between the times when
we do want we do want to do things maybe
quite fast for a few minutes and then
leave hours or days and before something
else and depending on distance and and
other things so yeah I don't I don't
disagree with that I suppose what you
say can work better in so if the people
having the conversation sort of
understand this then it works really
well it can work harder in cases or
where the employer has maybe more power
than the employee so it will kind of
vary from situation to situation just
just to jump in quickly I've looked at
people who are starting their first
dating and their method during messaging
messaging each other on something like
messenger or or what's up and so if a
tenth of a second is about the average
gap between people in a conversation you
what you notice the interacting that's
doing is kind of calibrating this is a
normal pace for us and then becoming
accountable or becoming someone who
probably isn't that keen on you if
there's leaving now what is a much
lengthier gap them what we had been
previously doing so you can kind of see
people calibrating that in something
like early dating quick comment the
truth let's that's for that question is
my wife and daughter have an ongoing
game of Scrabble when especially only
when were traveling I've never seen me
play Scrabble live face to face ever and
so a couple times a day don't just make
a move here and there it's not demanding
and and it's not about playing Scrabble
it's just a way of touching intimacy
it's saying I love you and I miss you
and and and that's it and it's
asynchronous there's no pressure and and
so the message has nothing to do with
Scrabble Scrabble is just a medium of
saying it in a way that how many times
can you say I love you right and and I
think that that aspect of Communications
is we have to there's the dark side of
it it's kind of like one of the white
hat things that's interesting that's not
planned but opportunistic that's neat to
pay to call out though because what else
are we missing
you know that's lovely because it's an
example where
you're not trying to you don't have a
particular goal in every kind of in Oslo
yeah I've never thought about that wait
till you with that question how
many points you getting Scott before I
love you no more seriously I want to
follow up on your comment so now we have
I mean if you look at the conversation
we have face to face conversation and we
have phone conversations and now we can
have texting conversations or we can
have email conversations what happens is
the contact Arum conversation is carried
out when different media and how does it
change when you when you analyze them is
that to me sir yeah well I I would go
back to the thing that I said right at
the start of my talk which is that
people still need to get stuff done so I
had a PhD student a few years ago who
was looking at face people live
constructing may have messenger chats
for example because she was interested
in when people are just friends and they
are talking what can we compare how
people are doing it on messenger to how
they might do it on the phone because we
know a lot about how people talk on the
phone or face to face and so we were
looking at the live construction of
messages and what eventually got sent
which of course is a bit different from
how things are put together and when it
comes to something like a request or an
invitation then we can see that people
are oriented to the same kinds of
contingencies and matters at stake that
they might be in face to face
conversation so you'll see people
building would you like to delete do you
want to delete and doing the kinds of
things that we see people doing in
face-to-face or telephone conversation
and and taking that time to precisely
design their turn for that recipient
it's just that of course when you're
face to face you can you can't hide the
fact that you're stopping and starting
that you can do when you are on
messenger so my gorgeous moments are
things like people writing xxxxX cursor
is sort of sitting there delete the all
the kisses put to delete them and then
send a sticky out tongue and I'm just
thinking about that
like in real life but basically the
answer is that if you start with action
and people have to do stuff and some of
these things that we imagine are very
different
aren't quite so different that that's a
really important point though there's
something very subtle here that we've
all talked about situated context and
everything's best for something at worst
or something else but here's the key
thing we talk about mobile we think
about the phone the physical device but
it's actually the activity that's mobile
and what's interesting to me in terms of
these different situations is when I'm
moving around and moving from context to
context how do I sustain the
conversation with whatever modalities
are available to me or appropriate and
so if I'm coming down the court or
talking the phone I have to describe for
example if I'm up by a whiteboard or if
you're physically I can use addictive
gesture to point and and indicate but
there's lots of other ways too and so
one of the things that's a design
challenge for those of us working in
research in this area is how do we make
the conversation be coherent and flew it
and have flow as I move through the
ecosystem and can do the best I can
in the with the available resources that
are that kind of are available and and
and so we have to know the points but
the transitions are actually eyes are
more important than the solutions of any
single point and and that's understudied
I mean it's not studied enough it
understates got a double me
this is for bill I've had the pleasure
of hearing you explain why it should be
you buy a D are not ubiquity and I
totally buy into it it's in all my talks
now but as you enumerate all these
various roles in which a communication
can take place and all the various roles
that the various actors can take all I
can think of is oh my god the
computational complexity of the
cross-product of all of these roles and
devices and places in your sense is
mind-boggling and I don't know how to
design for it what is our design
principle for this kind of drew
communication so Ken Hinkley I thought
said some wise things and he's talking
that just before lunch on the connected
devices saying we have all these we can
enumerate all of these this super
connected graph that's super complex but
actually it reality the vast majority of
those arcs in that graph have in their
critical path a note that says magic
happens here that is we don't know how
to do them so we can just prune those
for now and that makes this problem much
simpler what we can do is we can do the
best we can which is better than what
we're doing now because a lot of things
I described or have been available for
for a decade and just not acted on so
it's the it's really important it's the
hardest part is researchers you describe
a vision but you if that's that's that's
this aspirational but it's not what I'm
advocating that we do tomorrow it's just
that's a driving principle now where's
the low-hanging fruit and and and anyhow
we don't know and and so at least in
picking the low-hanging fruit we'll get
the insights that will help us go
further and figure out where we might
have insights or as soon as something
comes up that we didn't expect exploit
it in a most effective way and not have
to get a bloody nose along the way also
at that people are very adaptive and
they can appropriate different
technologies whether they're speaking on
the phone whether it's videoconferencing
and they understand the affordances of
that technology and will speak slowly or
they will
you know they aren't they're very good
at picking up so we don't always have to
be designing for the perfect flowing
conversation because I think people are
quite good at working it out for
themselves
my name is chella Rajan I'm with the
Indian Institute of Technology Madras I
don't work on digital technology so this
has been a fascinating day for me but I
wanted to pick up on something
konstantin said about you know he used
he's not a Luddite and i want to sort of
speak a little bit in defense of
Luddites partly because I think the slow
movements and the you know the refusal
of work the anti productivity movements
I think they're telling us something
that we ought to pay attention to even
the original Luddites were were really
sort of not against technology per se
but against the sort of industrial
technology and the kinds of tools
associated with that and and and their
crisis was a crisis of a loss of craft a
loss of you know social solidarity and
so on in fact one of the words that I
think is gone gone missing from our
conversation is the word solidarity
which was you know one of the three
terms of the French Revolution
fraternities sort of gone away because
it leads to a certain sort of emergent
outcome that that we've we've we've
forgotten how to sort of articulate and
think about I was wondering if you know
some of you could comment on on what
some of these technologies might do in
in order to sort of enhance social
outcomes or emergent outcomes like
solidarity I mean the reason why I am I
was resisting the the term like that is
that there are so many ways in which for
me professionally technology has made my
life much much easier and much better so
I didn't want to sort of come across as
and and specifically what's called
information communication technology has
made my kind of day-to-day life in terms
of work-life balance even much better so
while I was kind of
sizing it and it does have this really
nasty side I for me the solution isn't
to either do away with or minimize it
kind of across the board that can have
positive effects for certain people at
certain times but I was kind of more
interested in how to rethink technology
to enable various kinds of slowness I
suppose and if that if that's compatible
with Luddite then I'm happy
bilberry one or any one Liz you want to
have a crack at how you design for
emergent properties of of social
interaction you can start because you've
been thinking about it a bit more well I
just think one of the interesting things
is is the idea I guess of how especially
if we think about about turn-taking and
conversation analysis how you know every
turn proposes a next action and then
those actions propose forward actions
you know they they propel us through an
imagined social space and not just one
of course the multiple potentialities in
any turn that has received by somebody
they don't have to sort of accept as it
were the proposed ticket of what they're
going to do they can choose to go
another kind of path and we're all kind
of I think imagining multiple sort of
social realities at certain levels as we
move through things so I guess what I'm
interested in is technologies that that
open up the spaces for where might I go
and actually that was sort of one of
things I really liked about advance talk
is proposing a space for oh I don't I'm
not quite sure I can imagine exactly
where to go with this other resource
this visualization so tools that can
sort of simply provide just a little bit
of a nudge to then put me into the next
sort of imagined space I think those
sounds really exciting you enjoy ya know
that's very much behind our thinking is
that often we design interfaces
graphical user interfaces to speed up
thinking and to get people to get to a
solution as fast as they can
so you can set filters up and then
quickly the system will give you a
result we're trying to do the opposite
by slowing them down whereby you know
there's something then you have to make
you have to come to some decision or you
have to interpret or make sense of that
data and the system could just you know
say well I think it's this there's a
correlation between this obesity is you
know increasing in developing countries
because of all the fast food and so on
and it could make the suggestions what
what we're trying to do is to encourage
people themselves to think through and
to externalize their thoughts and that's
the kind of slowing down so having these
kinds of suggestions or nudges or saying
well why don't you look at this date or
have you thought about looking at that
can you know get it struck guide the
conversation in certain ways that
wouldn't have otherwise and then that
can lead to different thoughts and
different ways of making connections
with the data and we were just using
visual data here but if it could be in
teaching kids it could be in all sorts
of contexts as to how you might guide
and and and and open up and slow down
people's thinking
so the accountant I haven't it's it's
really interesting because it's
reflected implicitly in the session and
this previous session on connected
devices is it's about future it what's
the future of X right and and here's the
deal in terms of statistics and all the
studies about the evolution of
technology if you're historian of
technology just look at the National
Academy of Science reports that came out
every five years on the evolution of
telecommunications biotech and
information technologies everything
takes about twenty years at least to get
from a first inception articulation to
the time it hits primetime and learning
about the last five years that you got
the hockey stick where it comes up to
general awareness it's always there it's
always accessible it's always visible
you just have to know where to look and
it's just a question how good are we at
prospecting so when people ask me about
the future what's gonna happen in the
next five years why I sometimes appeared
to be mister smartypants pretending I
know what's not because I'm anything
other than a bit of a prospector I've
already seen fifteen years of history to
inform what's going to happen
what's possible to happen in the next
five years so for example it's not
necessarily some new technology there's
no deus ex machina that comes out and
does it what there is this for example
on turn-taking when you're driving your
car and you're in the middle of a
conversation you no matter how
intelligent the speech agent is that's
giving you directions guess what it's
got a microphone it can hear what's
going on in the car it doesn't pay
attention at all it just steps right on
top of you
so it has no turn taking in terms of
knowing when to come in to the in terms
of social graces it's just file it's
everything it's just wrong and second of
all in many cases it could deliver the
information about turning in non speech
audio which in a way uses different part
of the cortex so you don't need that
speech and and you could actually
maintain your conversation which may
have to do with rote finding and give it
to you and you get both those channels
simultaneously without task interference
so there's there's a whole range of
think of that is simply how do you ebed
use knowing what we know from the social
sciences and so on and about
communication science to leverage the
technologies that are already there
maybe in their infancy so that by the
time the cost/benefit that never my you
know mass the context of scale occur or
we want to trigger it we can actually do
it right and not have to struggle
through the kind of things that happened
with mobile phones be where they were
ringing everywhere because we had the
technology but we hadn't designed the
affordances that would accelerate the
adoption of appropriate social
conventions in their usage let's get in
one last question we got up there so I
want to say thank you to all the
panelists for really interesting diverse
provocative presentations the question
that I want to ask has to do with the
title of the session and the ways that
it manifests differently in each of your
talks right so you have Bill talking
about communication is to commune you
have Constantine talking about
communication isn't just information
exchange it's understanding each other
you have Elizabeth talking about people
understanding each other and these
really interesting fraud emerging
context
you have owned talking about you know
communication is like the the virtual
agent of the voice agent prompting you
to think in a different way and I find
myself wondering what the common thread
is like these these all feel like really
provocatively different approaches when
you the four of you reflect back on it
what's the thing that you see tying it
together as being about communication
they complete me and vice first I think
it's we all gave the same talk in some
ways I think that's my feeling I don't
know did we just filled it each other's
gaps the answer is yes I think you felt
more tensions across our talks then than
we did so I want to hear more about why
you think these are radically different
I was kind of thinking oh we're all kind
of quite similar in a way so I'm pleased
to hear you don't think this I don't
know that it's radically different but
you're all emphasizing different aspects
of it or it's sort of like the de silly
analogy with the people in the elephant
right oh it's a thing with tusks it's
got big ears whatever um and I guess
what I'm trying to understand is what is
the whole like how does this fit
together to make an agglomeration them
so they've hit a worthy you know just I
think it was also communication or work
is a very broad title for this session
whereas some of the other sessions are
very much more specific so you may see
more commonality across the talks but I
think what you got here was rich
diversity of how you can think about
communication at work and from the
philosophy to the you know social
aspects conversational you know a
theoretical analytic approach to future
technologies so I think you got a you
know
a smorgasbord if you like but it's also
chance evil genius of actually it
absorbing Constantine's message insane
you'll find out tomorrow as you absorb
it and if I can could you say I think
obviously what communication might be
best useful will really differ from one
profession to another one work context
to another so I was kind of giving a few
examples and maybe we're all giving a
few examples from context that we've
been working in or or I used to but it's
not as if there's a sort of catch-all
this is what it should be used for in
the future because it can be radically
different though
I always shocked every time like the
plumber comes and even he has to like do
some emails so maybe there is some
similarity across the world but I think
for me I I study people interacting in
workplaces of diverse kinds and I don't
really study
I'm not computer scientist and I don't
know very much at all about a lot of
their questions and answers that you you
all know but for me one thing that is it
does connect us a little bit is this
idea of continuous conversations lapsed
conversations having to pick them up
multimodal conversations and slowing
them down and it all comes together for
me in those crisis negotiations which
could be nine hours long where there is
no technology there is no extra
resources that you can bring to bear you
stop and start you have to stop and
start and the only thing that you can do
is actually use your voice to keep
someone talking and it's it's kind of
mundane in a way and it's just human
skill that and that's the only thing
that you can do for nine hours so I like
the fact that you talked about slow and
you talked about lapsing and starting
and restarting and it's someone's
workplace and it's very ordinary but
it's important to look at the very very
ordinary yeah there's a lot of skill in
the very ordinary yeah I think it's what
ties this together all right so it's
thought they have a timer thank you so
much can we thank all of our parents
speakers one more time
I believe there's now networking time so
you can go out and talk even more to the
to the speakers thanks very much
[Applause]